and questioning over to the attorneys a
few matters first of all i'm going to
swear you in so that all your answers
are under oath
okay if you could raise your right hand
do you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury that you will truthfully answer
all questions about your qualifications
to serve as a juror
all right thank you um i am going to
keep my mask on
and the attorneys have plexiglass in
front of them you have plexiglass in
front of you and we have plexiglass
between us
and i'll keep my mask on you however me
if you wish to be heard more clearly or
just uh if it's more comfortable you can
take it off at any point if you'd like
okay well if if they can't hear me
just let me know and i'll take it off
okay and generally i can understand you
we might have you pull just a little
closer to the microphone not right on
top of it but that's good
and unfortunately it doesn't move very
well it's pretty much hardwired
so that's good that i can hear you and
i'm sure they will as well
okay uh like i say if it's more
comfortable at any point
feel free okay i kind of leave it to you
to decide that
so uh you filled out a questionnaire and
it looks like you gave it a lot of
thought we appreciate that
uh is there anything or first of all is
everything true on that questionnaire
is there anything not true yeah is there
anything that no anything you wanted to
add or amend
i don't think so yeah just because
sometimes you know you fill it out in
december
and people realize oh i probably should
have put this you know in reflection
there might have been more information
or maybe even you change some of the
opinions in it um
anything you can think of right off the
bat uh
and it doesn't have to be i'm just
saying if there is no i don't think so i
i don't remember exactly what i said
about
how easy or difficult it would be to be
impartial
right and i think we'll talk about that
a little bit okay
and the lawyers when they're talking to
you uh
will kind of refresh your memory with
specific items
so feel free to have them read back what
your answer was
is almost more common than that that
most jurors say i don't remember what i
said in answer to that question
so feel free to ask for a prompt there
and just a reminder that anything you
say even if it's different
than what was in the questionnaire
that's perfectly fine all we're looking
for are honest candid
answers the only failure as a juror is
if you say something that's not true
uh about yourself okay yep
uh now you were not supposed to read any
articles and the questionnaire told you
avoid all media
but we realize that
you uh maybe expose inadvertently
information about the case you see a
headline maybe a friend talks to you
about the case and since we told you
don't tell anybody your potential juror
you can't exactly stop them did anything
like that happen to you that you've come
across to any inadvertent
inadvertently any information about the
case or any
related civil litigation or the parties
of the attorneys anything like that
uh no okay oh uh
right
now the reason why we ask all these
questions is obviously we you need to
decide the case just on
uh what's in the courtroom the evidence
and the laws i give it to you
and if you can do that great but if just
knowing yourself if you say
i can't i would like to i would try to
but just knowing myself i know that i
couldn't be
impartial for example and i bring that
up because there's quite a bit in your
question
about that and it's not a failure as a
juror to say
if you can't be impartial you can't um
if you can be impartial also a good
answer if that's the truth
so let's talk about partiality or
impartiality
do you think in this case you could be
an impartial juror
that's the biggest struggle i have all
right tell me a little bit more about
kind of your thought process i um
i i didn't even see the whole video i
saw
as much as i could take the video and i
was
i was appalled by what i saw and
that feeling continues to be with me
um and then i thought well can i
move from that can i
uh find myself in a position where
it's almost like i can forget that i've
seen it or something
right and it's i've been struggling with
that now for months
and i can't make any headway on it okay
uh let's talk about it just a little bit
uh
if this were well i guess would you
be in the same position as a juror as
far as your partiality
if it was a
not quite such a high profile case
and you would not say more about what
you mean by that well and i guess
let's say it's something you really
haven't seen much about
and but maybe the nature of the charges
would
uh cause you to be that i can't be
impartial i
uh i can truly be a blank slate
even if the charges were similar
different case totally
okay well the the thing that hangs me up
a lot on this one is that as i
understood it the
um immediate error that george floyd
made was in trying to pass a counterfeit
bill at least i think it was counter
anyway
and then the action that was taken
seemed to me to be inappropriate
um more
uh physical force
than seem to go with that kind of a
charge
and um
i mean if anything maybe mr floyd needed
more
some medical attention before the other
took place
you know the charge and
uh to exert that kind of force for that
long
just just seemed out of line to me okay
it sounds like a fairly firmly
entrenched
opinion that's the problem yeah yeah and
i want to make something clear
i have never met a juror in my 14 years
of the bench roughly 14 years of the
binge
who did not try to do their duty and did
not try to be fair and impartial but
recognizing that trying in this case
is not good enough do you can you
looking inside yourselves
can you be impartial
i wish i could say for sure that i could
right
and i cannot say that for sure i i think
i would be tainted
well i mean you mentioned taint one of
the things that is one of our bedrock
principles
is the presumption of innocence and
presuming someone
is innocent of the charge and
sometimes based on what you've seen and
heard
people cannot do that do you think you
fall into that category
that it would be very hard i think you
mentioned that in one of your
questionnaires
answers yeah i'm i'm
i'm sorry that i i i
don't apologize no um it is what it is
and i'm
and i'm sorry to mr children i'm sorry
to the court but i
i that's just where i am i cannot i
could not
say i honestly would be an impartial
juror all right well sir i do appreciate
your honesty and you're willing to
to say that if that is in fact the truth
and i i have every reason to believe it
is
it's clear from your questionnaire that
you are a thoughtful person
that you put a lot of introspection into
this
uh the answers you've given not only
today but in the question here so
i do appreciate your time and you're
taking the time to do all this
i am going to excuse you from this jury
um so
you're off jury service unless you get a
summons in the future okay all right and
i
if i can just add one other thing when
it first
came i saw that because of my age i
could ask to be excused
you can and i thought well i'm a
reasonably healthy 75 year old
i should be able to to do this and so i
thought well i'll proceed with it and
see what i can do
well i appreciate that because a lot of
people exercise that right right off the
bat
so i appreciate your willingness to do
your civic duty but recognition
that uh there are limits yeah uh so
thank you so much you can go with the
difference thank you you bet you can
take that and give that to them okay
all right thank you
yes 55 i believe
okay
all right come on up
morning and you are juror 55
correct correct all right a couple
things before i turn it
over to the attorneys for questioning uh
first thing is to swear you in so that
all your answers are on your old so if
you could raise your right hand
you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury that you will truthfully answer
all
questions about your qualifications to
serve as a juror i do
all right thank you now i'm wearing a
mask i'll continue to do so you have
plexiglas between us and in front of you
the attorneys have plexiglas in front of
them now
my point here is if you would like to
remove your mask to be heard more
clearly
or because it would be more comfortable
for you feel free to do so and i'm kind
of leaving it to you
how you want to proceed um in any case
uh
if you could speak near the microphone i
think actually you're about right okay
i think that generally will pick you up
and i'll adjust
as much as i can to make sure that you
are heard
uh first of all you filled out the
questionnaire thank you so much for
taking the time to do that
and to submit it to us there's a lot of
good information there for the lawyers
to ask you about
first of all is everything true on the
questionnaire yes and
any changes or additions to the
questionnaire that you can think of
right now
no all right the questionnaire did
advise you not to read any articles
avoid any media about this but
we recognize back in december when you
fill this out or january
that time has passed you inadvertently
may have been exposed to some
information about this case for example
maybe
seen a headline in passing or a friend
or relatives
talks to you about the case and we told
you don't tell anybody you're a juror so
you couldn't exactly stop people
uh from doing that um
is uh have you learned anything about
this case since
december and as you sit here today no
i've
chosen to avoid it as much as possible
okay great
um so nothing about not only the facts
of the case but about
maybe the parties any related litigation
anything like that no okay
any pre-trial matters anything about the
case or the procedures that have been
around the case no
okay excellent the whole point is uh
as a juror you have to decide this case
only on the evidence that you hear in
the courtroom
apply the law as i give it to you and so
while everybody has heard something
about the case
uh to varying degrees
do you think you could do that is put
aside anything you may have heard or
seen about this case
and decide the case just on what you
hear in the courtroom and apply
just that i give to you yes i do okay
all right um you were given a list of
witnesses
anybody look familiar on that list no
all right
all right uh we had an estimate of trial
of
uh four weeks basically and
i think you had some concerns about the
length of the trial can you tell me
about those um
just for my work purposes um
just to let my employers know how long
have we done and because i am working on
some projects right now just how to
um deal with those without college
causing questions upon my colleagues is
where i'm at
okay and you you mentioned uh
financially it might be hard for you
uh have you found out does your employer
pay you for jury duty yeah
that's all taken care of and yes so i
don't have to worry about that anymore
all right so that's not a concern it's
more of the the substance of your work
and correct do you think you might be
trying to do some work after hours to
uh yes i've had um lawn discussions with
my
employer just to be prepared
and we've already worked out the working
agreement so
i'm good okay all right
and when asked whether you weren't sure
you want to be on the jury and uh
you know that some because do you have
concerns for your personal safety
um i do for afterwards because i know
then it will be a public information and
it really depends on how the trial
the end result is and i um being as this
is new to me i just
don't know what i'm to be facing right
and
just want to be prepared okay and you
understand that
uh you are anonymous at this point will
remain so through the trial
at some point in the future and not even
immediately after the verdict
that's up to me to determine on when
it's appropriate to do so
i would uh your name would become public
a part of the public record
that doesn't mean you have to talk to
anybody but it could become part of the
public right correct
knowing all that do you think you could
decide this case
without worrying well i better come to a
this verdict or this verdict because
otherwise i might be in trouble
um the verdict isn't the role answer
it's the fact of
how people perceive it because everybody
should perceive it differently based on
the outcome
um it helps me to know that it's not
going to be public
right away because hopefully some time
will have passed before it's public and
everybody will move on right okay great
i'm sure the lawyers will probably
follow up on that as well
uh do you have any questions before i
turn you over to the attorneys
no all right mr nelson as juror number
55 you may inquire
[Music]
good morning ma'am good morning um
what i'd like to do here this morning is
ask you some kind of general
broader questions about yourself about
your experiences
and then focus into some of the
questions that you answered
on the questionnaire all right um
so uh assume you and i met under a
different circumstance at a social event
or a party
um and we're engaged in a conversation
what are a couple of things i'm gonna
walk away knowing about you
after that conversation um
depends on the topic of conversation of
course um
i'm a single parent i
i work in the health care field i
sell pampered chef um as a side hobby
those are the main things i talk about
with people okay
and um you have two children right
correct
and one's uh older and one's in her
teens or his teens
correct okay um
when you at some point you learned that
you were a prospective juror in this
particular case
right um what was your initial reaction
to learning that you were being called
in this particular case
um being as it's my first time
i thought wow first time um
on such a big case kind of a thrill
and passion at the same time because i
don't
with everything going on in the world
now you just never know
how things are perceived and
i my first reaction is i'm going to do
the best i can if chosen
because that would be how things work
out i'm going to give my best opinion
um and make the case very fair okay
great um can you think of a situation
in your personal or professional life
where you've been required to sort of
step in and resolve a conflict between
two people
um in my current role i do that quite
often okay i work
a lot with the patients if there's
patient issues i'm usually the one of
the
first people out there to deal with the
patient and help resolve the issues that
they are dealing with
our particular clinic okay um and so
when you're involved in
that kind of a process how do you
how do you approach the resolution of
conflict what is it
what are some tools you bring to that
well first is listening
you have to listen to everything um
sometimes they just need to vent
and then you pretty much have to figure
out what is their main
issue and try to resolve it and see if i
can resolve it within my means
if not i'll do my best to come up with a
win-win
for both of us okay now you understand
that
um i guess in in the context of being a
juror
that's ultimately what part of what your
role is is
conflict resolution correct um there's
obviously a conflict between the parties
and
in this case as well as um there may be
conflict that arises
in the jury room correct okay
um so in if you were let me ask you this
if you were in the jury room
and a particular piece of information
came
comes out in trial right and one group
of people
is really they think they're adamant
that this is the most important piece of
evidence
another group of people is saying well
that may not be
as relevant how do you approach that
situation
i would have to be neutral and i have to
give each
group the opportunity to show why they
feel that way
and yet after hearing both parties come
up with my own resolution and say well
what about this
because i'm going to have to share my
opinion at some point in time
but being able to hear both parties a
lot of times that's all they want to
know and then it's a
matter of you trying to bring out
things that well i'm questioning this
why are you saying this
and why are you saying this and maybe
even
possibly have some insight from both
parties on different ways of looking at
things
so um listening to both sides of the
story is an important
factor and looking at what other
information may support
one side or the other isn't incorrect
okay
how about in your personal or
professional life um
a situation where you have been called
upon to determine
who's telling the truth about a certain
circumstance
um i would say more in my professional i
deal with this more
but it's a matter of gathering the facts
and i'm hoping i will be presented the
facts
to know how to make that decision okay
how can you think of a situation in your
life where you were 100
certain of something you formed an
opinion only to
later learn that you were wrong
nothing comes to mind i'm sorry
recognize it's a possibility
oh oh yes always would you be the type
of person who um
learns from and it tries to apply that
to similar situations in the future or
would you that be the person kind of
brushes it off and says you know
mistakes happen i use it as a learning
opportunity for sure
going back to the um
you know the situation let's put
yourself back in that jury deliberation
room
and rather than being two sort of
competing factions
over a piece of evidence you are now the
person who's adamant
about this information is incredibly
important
right but a contingency of the other
jurors are saying it's not that
important
are you the type of person who can you
know kind of stand by her principles if
you form that opinion
or are you gonna just uh agree with the
others simply to build consensus
i'm the type of person that is going to
um expect or want them to hear my side
of the opinion and
have them try to prove me wrong so that
i can show them maybe a different side
of something
i'm not gonna just go with the flow type
of thing
especially if i feel really strong about
something i'm definitely gonna
want to be heard but you'd still be
willing to re-examine your views on
oh absolutely um
the last kind of general question is
your job as a juror
is to hear all of the evidence in court
right
set aside anything you may have learned
before that's not presented in court
and at the conclusion of the case the
judge will present you with
a the law right are you
able to read the law and apply it as the
judge gives it to you
even if you think the law is wrong
or should be changed i'm not in a
position to change the law
i'm in the position to uphold the law
and bring it forward to whatever the
case is okay
so i'm gonna focus your attention on a
couple of your questions
and um again no one's trying to trick
you
or anything of that nature if you want i
will in all likelihood just simply read
you your responses
okay and we will then um
explore it a little further okay
so the um the first question
kind of asks you to write down what you
remember
seeing or hearing about this case in the
news
or the media and in your
[Music]
answer to that you wrote i heard about
this on the news
but could never fully watch the whole
thing
as this disturbed me that the officer
didn't change
or remove his knee placement do you
remember i mean
yep okay now i wanna by the thing
we're talking about a video is that
correct correct
and i want to make sure we're kind of on
the same page
there was a video that was taken by a
bystander that video got uploaded to
facebook
it went viral and it became a news story
correct
is that the video that you're
referencing yes
and um there's a question later in the
questionnaire that asks you how many
times you've watched that video
and you wrote i believe once but i
didn't even finish the whole thing
correct
so in terms of that video how did you
come
uh to be familiar with that video was it
through social media
was it through the news media how did
you learn about that video
the news media okay and so the videos
that were shown on
news stories were they more smaller
clips
or as a part of a larger story or did
were you watching some news media
and there was a link to watch the entire
video it was a short clip
okay did you ever go and
like i want to see what all i want to
see what's more about this and
look up the actual full video to watch
that
no i have not okay
um when you
were asked about that video you said
that
you couldn't watch it in full because it
was too disturbing for me do you
remember that
correct is it fair to say that you
formed an opinion
about what was happening in that video
simply based on
watching that video or what parts of it
you watched i would say it's the fact
that
someone was harming someone else from
what i'm seeing and i just couldn't
watch that whether um
just based on the human human
information that was being presented
during that video
i just couldn't watch it anymore okay
now
let me ask you there was a question
later in the questionnaire
about being able to see graphic images
graphic types of whether it be video or
photographs
and you had some trepidation about that
would you agree with that
you said trepidation yeah like just
nervous like you were
concerned about that um yes i was
concerned about it
okay so it's it's entirely possible that
the
entirety of that video could be
admitted as evidence in this case would
you be able to watch the entire
video i wouldn't
based on my role in this i would i would
have to
because that's part of the whole
evidence now
also um would you
agree that that video is really only a
part of the story correct i definitely
agree with that
okay um and you have never gone and have
you ever seen any
other videos of this incident whether
they be the police officers body worn
cameras
or any of the like surveillance videos
that were released
no i have not okay um are you would you
be able to
um again wait until all of the evidence
is presented
and decide this case based on the entire
story
and both sides of that story
fairly and impartially that is my role
here
um now you were asked a couple of
questions about your general impression
of both mr chauvin and mr floyd
and with respect to mr chauvin you
checked
somewhat negative that you had formed a
somewhat negative impression of mr
chauvin
and you wrote i think they could have
handled it differently
i got the impression he didn't care
about
george floyd or gf is what you
technically wrote
um it's okay to have an opinion
all right we all have our own opinions
about virtually everything
um can you set that opinion aside and
you've you formed a somewhat unfavorable
opinion of my client
agreed correct can you set your opinion
aside
and judge this case based on the facts
um i believe i stated in my
questionnaire that i don't know that i
based on the little clip that i've seen
that i've even gotten all the facts
to form an opinion and i won't be able
to form an opinion on him until i have
all the facts
and that's what someone should do okay
and um feeling the same way about mr
floyd as well
yes i think he has more to bring to the
table
as as as chavan does okay
now in terms of um some of the general
rules of law you were asked some
questions
um you're able to apply the presumption
of innocence to mr chauvin at this point
yes you understand um that under our
system of uh law under our constitution
mr schulman has nothing to prove here no
um he doesn't have to ask we don't have
to ask a single question we don't have
to introduce a single piece of evidence
we don't have to
to participate in this process we have
any problem with that
no because i feel right now he's
innocent until we can prove otherwise
and i think you've made that quite clear
in the course of your
questionnaire so i appreciate it um you
were asked a question
about your impression of whether
the community has been negatively or
positively affected by any of the events
that have taken place in the twin cities
area
since mr floyd's death and you wrote i
think
all our communities took a beating from
these
unfortunately a negative one everyone
was scared it was going to come to their
neighborhood
so i mean can you explain what you kind
of mean by that
um there's just a lot of riots that were
being taken place around the twin cities
area and i know
in other communities as well and
based on where i lived there was one
taking place not too far from
where i live and that that's pretty far
from minneapolis and so it wasn't
it kind of spread to other areas
outside of where the incident happened
okay
um do you think there's a between
a protest oh yes um
can you see the difference between uh
the protests that occurred after mr
floyd's death
and the riots that took place yes do you
think that they're one in the same
no
you were asked about um past uh your
your observations or your own personal
past police contacts
and you were asked the question have you
ever personally seen the police use more
force than was needed
you wrote yes and you wrote i wouldn't
say
more force but i have seen more officers
respond to a situation
than i thought should or needed to a
teen
teenager unarmed nothing in hands but a
water bottle
get addressed at a park regarding his
actions
over four officers showed up i felt like
he was being harassed
that's what you yeah can you just tell
me a little bit more about that
situation
um i was out in the parks walking with
her
my girlfriend we were sitting on a bench
and
a young man came walking down the path
um
tennis shoe shoes all he had in the
water is a water bottle and a lady came
up and was yelling at him and
and then pretty soon a cop showed up and
we're in
where the playground is for younger kids
and pretty soon there was four cops
there
and i'm thinking he is unarmed he's got
a water bottle
i don't understand and it was in a
public place
you're causing to me undo they could
have taken him someplace
where it was less public to make such
whatever happened he ended up walking
away
okay so you just thought that they um
more officers showed up
they kind of harassed the kid or young
man i should say
and um it was unneces an unnecessary
police response would that be a fair
summary
i would agree yes is there anything
about that situation
that would affect your view of this case
like would you say
you know so many officers showed up on
this case
i wouldn't don't that i i only know what
that little clip showed me i don't even
know how many officers were there how
many showed up
i'm just witnessing based on what
my um incident was at the park that and
this was after
the incident and i think tops are
probably on edge right now they're
looked at in the microscope and it's
that's too bad because that's not their
role they're here to protect us and
and um it's just too bad that
i witnessed that particular incident on
a
young boy with just a water bottle in
his hand i mean if
he had anything that i felt in his hand
that was
a threat then i totally agree with the
number of officers that showed up
okay fair enough um there were a list of
um several kind of broad statements
and you were asked to um
sort of rank your opinion of these
statements from
strongly agree to strongly disagree okay
okay um so my question is
about just a couple of those i want to
follow up you were asked
the question
[Music]
police in my community make me
feel safe and you checked the box i
somewhat agree with that can you explain
your thinking there
that was just based off that incident
that i'd seen in the park
okay um
you were asked the question police in
this country
treat whites and blacks equally and you
somewhat
disagreed with that i
think it's really based on the officer
and their
opinions and how they address people
i know i without personal experience but
i've just heard that some
some officers aren't the best and they
don't treat everybody equally and
i think they should doesn't matter who
they are
they should treat everybody the same
whether they pull them over for this
they pull them over for that
we shouldn't have based on your
racial um and how you look
determine how you get treated when you
get pulled over okay
fair enough you were
asked your opinions on both
black lives matter and blue lives matter
and i believe you sort of have the same
response
at least generally you write i believe
all lives matter
doesn't matter the color of their skin
or nationality they are
all lives matter underlined i
truly believe that um and but yet your
your opinion of black lives matters was
somewhat unfavorable why would that be
um i'm not sure um why i answered that
because i'm
i still strongly believe that all lives
matter doesn't matter
who they are what they are they all
matter
we're all important
now i know um your uh
employment takes you or you work in a
clinic
setting okay and i'm assuming with
doctors and nurses
and you have relationships with doctors
and nurses in a professional context
correct
if you were a juror on this case um
would you call up one of your doctor or
nurse friends and say this is what these
doctors are saying
absolutely not okay
um you did initially i just want to make
sure i heard correctly you initially
had some concerns about your employment
and
finances and things like that that's all
been taken care of
um the last question you were asked as a
part of this questionnaire is do you
want to serve as a juror on this case
and you check the box not sure you are
nervous
you wrote i'm nervous i've never been a
juror before and to be on such a high
profile case
would people know i am a juror on this
case during or after
question would i question
during and after i don't want to walk
around or be in my home and not feel
safe that's what you wrote
yep so let me ask you a couple of
follow-up questions on them
how did you feel when you came down to
the government center and saw
sort of the fortifications for lack of a
better word
around the area um
a little concerned but there wasn't as
many there as i
anticipated to be so that made me feel
better um but knowing that there's so
much security here
i feel better and the fact that the
jurors are not going to be
names aren't going to be released before
during or hopefully a while after
um being as i'm new to this i didn't
know what to expect and so
i just was voicing my opinion because i
just didn't know what i didn't know
sure so so now that you have seen
um how we're dealing with this situation
you know your
anonymity is we're attempting to protect
your anonymity
you feel more comfortable and willing to
serve yes
i may have a moment
all right mr slisher thank you
good morning good morning
noticed on your questionnaire you
indicated one of your hobbies is
motorcycle riding
that's correct right you tell me about
that a little bit um i have a
2018 soft tail heritage classic and i
like to ride whenever i can
okay um do you uh just within the state
or do you travel
um beans being it's just recently new so
i just
strictly stay within the twin cities
kind of metropolitan outskirts area
not a lot of writing i do haven't
ventured out to sturgis or anything
no no no not not recently many many many
years ago i did
but all right
and which what got you interested in uh
in motorcycle riding
what interests me yes um my late husband
was really into it so i
um got my license just to make sure that
if anything happened to him i could
still ride
and i ride
with him kind of now in the spirit
so well thank you for telling us about
that
you're asked uh some questions about the
difference between
a protest and a riot and you you said
you understood there is a difference
what i would like to ask you is if you
can tell us in your own words
as best you can what is the difference
in your mind between a
protest and a riot a protest is somebody
walking around with signs who made note
of a particular
topic or interest and a riot is one when
they
actually do harm to buildings to cause
attention
and you said that there were some riots
or property damage that happened
fairly close to your residence is that
right correct
what went through your mind when this
was all uh unfolding
i'm concerned that it was an incumbent
in my neighborhood and
wondered what do i do during that
circumstance
and i guess i just
was concerned that i what do i do do i
call the police does it with that
you know put salt in the wound do i just
let them do their thing
i mean i think with anybody it was
the question how do they handle it if it
comes close to them
and what did you ultimately do nothing
i stayed in my home and did nothing and
hoped that it didn't come did that work
out it did
you didn't suffer any property damage or
anything like that
no sir he did not and did any of your
friends
neighbors relatives suffer any property
damage
no
you indicated that you watched the video
one time but you
have not watched it since because you
found it uh disturbing is that right
um to be clear i've never watched the
full thing okay so i
don't even know what happened after
i heard him say something i totally shut
it off so i've never seen the whole
video in full in its full
entirety and and
you shut it off specifically because you
found it disturbing correct
but you've indicated that you know if
that's something that you had to view
again you would be able to do that
i would have to
taking you back to your description
of the incident you saw at the park in
which you believe that officers use too
much force
you recall that correct yes do you
recall the race of the individual
against whom you believe they
use too much force um the individual the
boy was white
not that that made any difference to me
but it was
just the fact that there were so many
officers
and you felt that under the
circumstances they they just simply over
responded correct
in and and i just want to uh
go over again the conversation that you
had as defense counsel about your views
of
black lives matter and you indicated
that you had a somewhat unfavorable view
of black lives matter and and said you
weren't really sure why you
why you wrote that the unfavorable view
of you know
reflection i still really don't know
where i was when i wrote that but all
maybe i'm
was thinking that sometimes um or maybe
they were taking it too far
i don't know exactly why i answered that
way i'd have to
probably try to remember where my mind
was at that time or
did i witness something or see something
or i just can't fully answer as to why i
would write that because
something must have happened or
triggered me or that because usually i
don't
like i said all lives matter to me it
doesn't matter who they are what they
are
they all matter because we're all
important in this world and
the question i had was maybe do you
associate that group with the
property damage or writing no no
and do you believe that if if
someone was to make the statement that
black lives matter or some other lives
matter that they're saying other lives
don't matter
it can be perceived like that and i
think they are just
making it um
maybe they felt and i don't know because
i'm not
black to know maybe they felt that they
were never heard
and that's why they are coming up with
black lives matter because
maybe they felt that they never were
seen
they never were heard and whereas i
don't believe that to be true but
i'm not them and i might see things in a
different view
and and so when you say someone could
perceive it uh
like that that that it could mean that
they're saying not all lives matter
do you perceive it that way when you
hear that someone say black lives matter
do you perceive that they're saying
that not all lives matter it can be
perceived whether i
perceive it like that
that's a great question um
i would probably just re tell them that
all lives matter
again so maybe i do perceive that they
think only black lives matter
and and um and then so
the next question or series of questions
had to uh
do with blue lives matter and so when
you hear
someone say blue lives matter do you
perceive that in the same way
that maybe they're saying not all lives
matter only blue lives matter
i took that to perceive everybody else
blue lies well maybe i'm misinformed i
don't know what blue lives matter mean
um but i took that to mean that
that's everybody else so i should follow
up i mean what is your understanding of
what that means if somebody were to say
blue lives matter
and have them clarify what do they mean
by blue what does blue mean
okay what did you think it meant when
you answered the survey
that meant everybody else everybody else
did you associate or have you ever
associated that
blue lives matter with police officers
oh so that's what that means as blue
means officers
huh um say that question again now
please
sure and i think you i think you
answered it but at the time you were
filling out the survey did you have an
understanding that
blue lives matter actually refers to
police officers
blue lives um i can honestly say no i
didn't perceive it like that because i
didn't know what blue meant
okay
well on a survey you indicated that you
believe that sometimes
local police departments will cover up
instances
of excessive force rather than to
correct it you said you
somewhat agreed with that proposition
you recall that
that's probably based on my witness to
the in the park
because when i was we were walking down
the path
and the officer told us to stay back
and i'm like well i'm kind of concerned
for this one kid there's
like five officers and he said stay back
and i'm like okay so
i mean that was my only i've never had
any incidents or
witnessed anything other than that one
incident at all with any
police officers at all it sounds like
that made an impact on you though you
remember how long ago that was
um it was last summer august september
it was a really nice day we were walking
we were just out for a long time we were
out for a long walk and that was just
something happened right in front of me
which i've never been witness to and
that's probably why
it's stuck with me because it's my only
incidence that i've seen
when the officer so you indicate that
you saw something that concerned you
but the officer told you to stay back
and repeated it
correct how did it make you feel when
the officer said that to you
um
[Music]
kind of like i didn't matter that i was
concerned with
the particular um
that was being um
harassed is how i looked at it um that i
should stay out of my
state mind your own business type of
thing
and you said that the officer said this
twice did you did you attempt to argue
with them or
ask a question no i'm not in any
position to argue with an officer i
just stay back okay do you know why he
said it twice
or um to probably make his point
across okay i don't know it wasn't in
response to you
asking a question or attempting to i
just was
like i said i was walking up to him and
he said stay back and i said well i just
i i just concerned for that kid and he
said stay back
okay and so i did okay
sometimes when i ask a question people
tell me i'm arguing
not you no all right
do you have any uh concerns that is with
the precautions we have here the
plexiglass and the mask wearing and
whatnot do you feel
that we've adequately taken steps to
reduce the risk of
cova 19. yes yep
do you think it's enough or maybe even
too far
one cannot be too cautious
uh one moment your honor
can you tell me a little bit more about
your your work as an executive assistant
what it is you you specifically do
without naming your employer
giving any identifying um yeah i work as
an executive assistant in clinton
minneapolis and
i assist the vp and director of our
actual building
so i work with a lot of her meetings
and his meetings just going over
things and issues that happen across our
building
that's pretty much summons up my my role
okay
and so you're working with someone in
the uh sort of an administrative
position you're not working with a
physician
i work with physicians only if it has to
do with meetings and such
not on a day-to-day basis do i get in
touch with them
i know who they are but i don't work
with them on a
direct basis at all so for example
working specifically with cardiologists
or pulmonologists
no not a only if it has to do with a
meeting request and i usually reach out
to their assistants
well is it fair to say that you
you do have and place trust in police
officers
i have a place of trust and that's their
role and that's
i i have nothing but to believe that
until they
show me something different and and so
with that
understanding that in this case uh
there will be law enforcement officers
who will be called to testify
there will be civilian bystanders who
will be called to testify
and you would be asked to judge their
credibility to determine whether or not
one should be believed another one
should be believed and
you know based on your trust in police
officers i just need to ask you if you
would be able to
look at the testimony of a police
officer in the in the same manner
that you would look at the testimony of
some other witness who wasn't a police
officer
perhaps a bystander absolutely doesn't
matter their uniform doesn't change who
they
are you don't think that you might tend
to
believe a police officer more simply
because
they are a police officer not
necessarily
right thank you very much but your honor
will pass for cause
juror number 55 you will be on this jury
oh
okay so uh we you can go about your
business until march
29th at 9 00 a.m which is when we
anticipate starting the trial itself
okay and so we will be in contact
probably to remind you
or to tell you if things have been
delayed i think you've already realized
sometimes there are delays yes and we
apologize for that but it's just
the way things happen so we do
appreciate your time here
and the deputy will take some stuff from
you on the way out but
uh unless you hear from us otherwise
march 29th at 9 am
uh you'll be escorted to that same
courtroom to wait okay so i
come in like the same process same
process as today same places
where to park all that kind of stuff
okay all the same
um and you'll be go to the same
courtroom to start off with okay
all right sounds good thank you
so
this is going to be juror 56
and we may not be able to get through
jira 56 completely but we'll give it a
try
so
so
so
[Music]
dana if we go to 12 30
yeah okay
morning sir morning you have a seat
right there okay
just put this right here yep wherever
you can find skates
all right well thank you for being here
this morning
and i'm going to first things where are
you in so that all your answers are
under oath
so if you can raise your right hand do
you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury
that you will truthfully answer all
questions about your qualifications to
serve as a juror
i do all right thank you and i'm going
to ask that you
uh speak into the microphone okay you
can yup uh
i'm gonna keep my mask on okay uh we
have plexiglass between us plexiglass in
front of you plexiglas in front of the
attorneys
yup so that's sufficient for us to say
if you'd like to take your mask off i'll
be more comfortable that's fine
uh that's fine that you can do that all
right
uh before i turn it over to the
attorneys i want to ask you a couple
questions
first of all everything's true on your
questionnaire yes
all right any changes or additions you
can think of offhand there is one
okay and that was in regards of knowing
a police officer
okay tell us about my questionnaire that
i did
well at the time i thought he was no
longer in the force
but it come to my attention that he is
now still on the force
okay and do you know which police
department this person is on i don't
know what
minneapolis but i don't know what
precinct okay
all right and i think you've just
illustrated one thing we find is that
people fill out a questionnaire in
december and then on reflection
they realize they're things oh i
probably should have put this in
or i found out new information yeah at
the time i didn't know
okay it came to my attention a family
member let me know that he did
he was let go and then he got back on
the floors okay
um
okay so anything else you can think of
that might be
you want to change or add to because
it's all right actually if you even
change something
right opinions evolve uh facts come to
light
that you think uh show that something
was inaccurate the most important thing
is that you just
give us as accurate and as honest uh
i mean there are some things that come
to my attention
you know that i've heard right on the
television it was hard for me to
get away with watching the television
because of
where i'm located at work at the break
room
they always have a tv in there and you
i think you've kind of anticipated our
next question is you're told in the
questionnaire to avoid all media and to
my
best i could right it's not uncommon
from the jurors we've talked to to find
that inadvertently
people have been exposed to more
information about the case they see
something on tv a quick headline or in
the newspaper
so tell us first of all what you
know about the case well i know
what i've seen on the video all right
have you watched the video a few times
i've watched it twice in its length
uh the whole thing the whole thing yes
have you sought out
that video or did it just when it came
up on the news
when it came up on the news all right
what facts do you recall from watching
the video
well i know the facts that uh
the officer had his knee on his neck
okay for over eight minutes okay
and i know there was other officers
okay there at the moment yep all right
and uh you form some opinions based on
what you've seen and correct
uh i'm gonna focus now on since you
filled out the questionnaire
and today uh
what have you heard or seen and again we
acknowledge that
sure you did your best to avoid it but
some things are unavoidable right
what information have you found about
this case or anything related to this
case
what i did here is that there was a
potential plea
okay but the attorney general
denied that plea okay and
i also know that the third degree was
put
back on the table okay and so these are
like headlines you've seen that yeah
okay um
do you think you could still presume
somebody innocent when you've got maybe
more information than you wanted
you can still presume the defendant
innocent or do you think
now from what i've seen it would be
tough okay
all right let me talk to the lawyers
just for a second
all right juror 56 i'm going to release
you from this panel
um it's not your fault that you
inadvertently got exposed to things that
would make it tough to be
right uh sitting as a juror in this case
uh because like i say
you're in your work situation in the
break room it's
hard to turn off the tv when everybody
else is watching it
you can't and we told you don't tell
anybody you're a potential juror so you
can't say
turn that off i don't know i wasn't
about to do that
all right and then so because of that
obviously not your fault
uh but i'm going to release you from
service on this panel and so in fact
you're released from jury service so
unless you get a
summons in the future you'd be fine okay
all right thank you very much thank you
sir yep have a good day
actually give to the deputy and he'll
take care of it
all right it's five to twelve we've run
out of jurors
so we're getting better at calibrating
how many jurors we have
although i still feel like a cat chasing
a laser pointer
but nevertheless i think we have no
choice but to recess until
1 30 the jurors are summoned for one
we've got three
so i think 1 30 would be just fine that
we start all right
see you at 1 30.
you